well after a two-year hiatus project  150's las vegas prom closet has returned  local high schoolers had the opportunity  today to pick out some free prom outfits  both girls and boys got to take their  pick of out of a thousand of gently used  dresses tuxes suits and accessories  organizers say they're so excited to be  able to put this event on again  we're very happy to be able to allow  students to come and shop get everything  they need for prom if they are asked or  want to ask somebody for prom nobody  wants to tell their kid that they're not  the ones that are going to be able to  participate we want to give high school  students what they need to stay in  school and blend  it's really a great program again the  event was free to high school students  who showed their student id